the abyss in this DLC we're going to
have to confront what it is and how
little we know about it but what do we
know well the abyss manifests in a
multitude of ways which is a point
acknowledged by the follower torch which
says that some forms of the abyss
manifest as pass within the body this
manifestation is called the pass of man
but it can also manifest as black flame
as the impenetrable fires of humanity as
human desire drawn towards life or as a
tale of human suffering applied to a
blade so whether it's pass sorcery
pyromancy or a miracle the abyss always
borders on humanity that's the one
constant it serves as a more disturbed
form of dark a good parallel is how
chaos is simply a more disturbed form of
the flame and finally the abyss is
either a part of you or you're fighting
against it and in the case of the
followers of Ferran they were the latter
if your kingdom became infected by the
abyss then you could expect the undead
legion of Ferran at your doorstep
clearly recognizable by their pointed
steel helms the legion were a caravan of
undead warriors who took upon the legacy
left by artorias the abyss walker'
and vowed to eradicate the abyss
wherever it was found we've talked about
Farren's undead legion before actually
in great depth and back then we thought
we knew what type of warriors served in
this traveling army there were the abyss
Watchers who were the elite fighters and
likely the vanguard taking the
frontlines there were the acolytes these
sorcerers of the Legion and there were
the watchdog's who looked after Ferran
keep itself while the troops went out
fighting but the final piece of the
puzzle and one we didn't know about
until now bringing up the rear guard of
the travelling army were the followers
of Ferran
warriors who were left behind when
Ferran and its Watchers fell to ruin so
the role of the followers was to do just
that to follow behind the caravan of
roaming undead as hollows who hunted
their compatriots taken by the abyss
once a warrior of Ferrand fell to the
abyss the tall lean followers quietly
appeared in groups to take them down
they would attack with this technique
that was honed to face men because those
yet to lose their human aspect of course
were the most commonly tainted so we see
this fighting style honed to face men in
our fights with them the followers fight
you as they used to fight their own
compatriots who were infected by the
abyss they surround you
the shield bearers sprint to place their
shield in your face while those behind
spit fire fire is said to have been
effective against the abyss since
ancient times and it's only natural that
the followers would have their torches
double as a weapon on a final command
the followers would hurl their spears at
their fallen foe to give the retired
warrior this honorable send-off this
concept of respecting fallen warriors
it's totally in keeping with the culture
of the legion that we've come to expect
look back at their homeland there's an
entire part of the Legion the watchdogs
who are devoted to and I quote defend
the sanctity of sleeping warriors and
there are multiple battlegrounds as well
where there's these respectful scenes of
swords thrust into the earth respecting
fallen warriors it's something that was
done for artorias it's something done in
their homeland and it's something
performed by the followers of Ferran the
follower Armour gives us the final line
which indicates how they ended up
forlorn and in the painted world very
and Elle
I quote Ferran and its Watchers fell to
ruin but the followers survived as a
wandering pack of hollows this shows
once more that undead can continue to
perform tasks even after they Hollow
they're not completely mindless and I
hope we learn more about this if we
visit Londo
so the followers outlived their fellow
warriors and instead of being a part of
the ruins of Ferren keep they continued
wandering for lon hollow they were drawn
into the painting where they quietly
rest beside the trees and the wolves at
least until an kindled ash comes to kill
them all promising for pari under fire
hey guys so I run a patreon page where I
can give people a little bit extra in
return for their support and that's
things like having access to videos a
little bit early streams you can get the
art I commissioned as a wallpaper things
like that so if that sounds interesting
check out the patreon page it's made all
of this possible really over the last
few years but regardless of that thank
you so much for watching and I'll see
you in the next one
[Music]